[Musique]
schumi on sait qu'on s'entend bien moi
je vous aime beaucoup j'apprécie
beaucoup vos produits pas folle je
trouve que vous faites des montres
connectés qui sont très bien et vous
avez des productions supercrew dans une
bonne écosystème avec des supers rapport
qualité prix et je dois vous avouer que
là pour le coup ça j'ai du mal à
comprendre
alors je vous explique pourquoi parce
qu'en fait ça ça ressemble énormément à
ça là on allait me troue wireless
personnes 2 shiomi là vous avez les
reposes 2 ce qui moi me chagrine c'est
que très clairement on voit que ce
produit là est vraiment aux dires et
aspire elle est pour moi c'est vraiment
pompey alors bien évidemment on va pas
avoir la même petite tarhouni sont
dessus bien évidemment c'est pas la même
taille mais lorsqu'on s'attaque à ces
produits qui sont aujourd'hui quand même
eu une référence dans leur domaine et
des il faut avoir des arguments en face
je ne dis pas que ce produit leur n'a
pas d'arguments mais en frontal très
clairement il fait pas le point et c'est
ça qui me gêne un petit peu si vous
voulez parce que on voit que le parti
pris là dessus c'est de venir chercher
les airpod l'expérience est la même on
ouvre notre petite boîte on va avoir
notre petite zone de recherche d'un
meilleur on va avoir sensiblement la
même chose va retrouver un petit peu les
mêmes codes là vous avez le bouton
l'arrière solaire pod là vous avez deux
boutons ici en latéral même s'ils sont
pas exactement les mêmes produits se
ressemblent énormément on est quand même
sur une grosse inspiration et le
problème s'il voulait c'est que je
trouve que déjà que le produit qui est
fait aujourd'hui est un plus gros souci
au niveau de la boîte n'aurait une autre
forme de boîte vous serez d'y aller ils
sortent des écouteurs trouve wireless
est super bien en plus de ça ils ont la
réduction active dessus et vu le plus
souvent tarifaire c'est vachement bien
mais c'est vrai que là - le bémol et moi
ce qui me gêne c'est le fait de se dire
on se met en frontal face à apple on
vient se positionner sur l'équivalent
des airs podz pour android
j'aurais préféré éventuellement qui est
un système de boîte un peu plus comme
les galaxies buzz ou un système un peu
différent tenir se différencier qu'on
peut me faire le mode veille
j'aurais trouvé ça intéressant là je
reste un peu sur ma faim regardez quand
même on est bien dans l'idée en tout cas
d'avoir des produits qui se ressemblent
énormément là vous avez production mis
là vous avez l'air poseurs c'est pas la
même chose ça c'est vraiment en intra là
c'est par le travail juste posé on ne
recherche pas exactement la même chose
mais néanmoins on vient
hague et je dirais les utilisateurs
d'apple ont bien sûr un produit qui s'en
rapproche
c'est pas exactement le même produit
c'est une évidence et ce que nous dira
xiaomi on va pas faire derrière poste on
cherche pas à faire des fautes mais ce
que j'aime chez shiomi c'est s'inspirer
des autres pour sortir leur propre copie
et des produits qui sont vraiment
intéressants même si beaucoup de
produits sont homogènes au niveau des
smartphones que ce soit chez chaumet ou
les autres donc on retrouve des produits
qui sont inspirés les uns des autres
j'aurais aimé que ses produits soient
plus inspiré et qu'ils aient aussi leur
propre personnalité
c'est ce qu'il manque un petit peu alors
on ne dira peut-être que si parce qu'ils
ont effectivement de la réduction bruit
active chose que n'ont pas les airs
pauvres ce qui n'aurait absolument aucun
sens vite leurs potes viennent juste se
pose donc c'est strictement imposée de
chercher afin de la réduction proactive
truc qui me gêne un petit peu avec ces
se produit que même si c'est pas un
choix délibéré de la part du show me de
se dire ce sont les repose ce sont
vraiment des bières pots de stands et
même s'ils ne le disent pas malgré tout
pour le consommateur lorsqu'on voit se
produit lorsqu'on louvre lorsqu'on le
prend dans les mains on voit très
clairement qu'il y a un travail qui est
fait pour qu'on dise ah bah tiens ça me
fait penser à des reposes c'est un peu d
r paul moins cher ça peut être bien
voilà ça c'est un truc qui me dérange un
peu
une fois qu'on passe ce point de vue là
et qu'on oublie les reposes balle et
produit il n'est pas extraordinaire
d'un autre côté il faut raison garder ce
produit là coûte 79 euros et 99 centimes
c'est normal qu'on les en ait pour son
argent je vous ai pas dit le seul truc
de différenciant pour moi c'est la boîte
voyez on le voit on a du bleu on a des
causes qui sont relativement différent
et ça pousse est vrai que se
différenciant why not au niveau du
packaging extérieur ça c'est plutôt bien
après le produit en lui-même j'aurais
attendu mieux en termes d'expériences
sonores
je vous explique je trouve que le son
est pas mauvais en lui même mais c'est
vrai que quand j'arrive avec une petite
boîte comme ça et avec des petits trucs
comme ça je les mets dans les oreilles
j'aspire à mieux et j'espère mieux
d'autant plus beau temps bon de la
réduction de bruit active je trouve que
le son est un peu brouillon on a des
médiums qui sont corrects on a des bases
c'est un peu brouillon ce n'est pas le
temps des liens et au niveau des aigus
pour vraiment très imprécis quand on les
trouve et je ne trouve pas ça génial
sous cape
il ya un déséquilibre au niveau de
l'audio personnellement je suis pas
particulièrement convaincu par la
qualité audio de ces produits quant à
l'arrêt de son bruit active on peut se
dire c'est marrant tiens j'ai mon petit
casque j'ai mes petits un trajet de la
réduction go est petit c'est plutôt rare
l'idée c'est qu'effectivement déjà
lorsque vous les mettez comme ça vous
avez une petite réduction passive pas ce
que ça veut dire vous chez vos oreilles
vu que ce sont des
intra ça ça me paraît quand même assez
normal et ensuite pouvez faire le choix
on leçons apprises pendant trois
secondes ici devenir activer ou
désactiver l'arrêt du sombre ou élective
la réduction de boue la réduction de
bruit c'est dur et bien réduction de
bruit active elle n'est pas si mauvaise
que ça dans la mesure où on est sur un
casque un peu moins 80 euros à côté de
ça joue ça apporte pas grand chose ça
veut dire un petit peu atténuée vous
entendez quand même ce qui se passe mais
c'est légèrement étouffé je peux dire
que ça gâche l'expérience mais on
pourrait s'attendre à mieux leurs débuts
en activant les intimant diawara temps
c'est quoi le gap c'est quoi la
différence à il ya une petite différence
s'atténue s'est pas non plus dingue
après il faut garder les pieds sur terre
on est sur un produit à 79 euros 99 va
pas lui demander la lune après il ya des
fous ils sont vraiment intéressants ces
produits il faut aussi le souligner
c'est le fait que eh bien ces petits
produits mais ils sont indépendants l'un
de l'autre
ça c'est assez intéressant vous avez
également un petit capteur qui va savoir
lorsque vous enlevez vos écouteurs ce
qui fait que par exemple lorsque
quelqu'un vous appelez vous enlevez vous
pouvez téléphoner avec un seul ça c'est
plutôt bien
lorsque vous les enlevez il ya le
reconnaissent et à ce moment là il va
couper la musique soit c'est des petites
options mais c'est vrai que c'est quand
même plutôt sympa autres banques sont
très sympas là dessus c'est ce petit
pavé tactile à l'arrière vous en avez un
de chaque côté donc il faut par avoir
des commandes différentes en fonte que
vous allez vouloir faire par exemple
j'ai les écouteurs quelqu'un appelle
d'apple tape ça décroche d'abel tape ça
raccroche
lorsque j'écoute de la musique d'apple
tu as salé played abel tape ça mais pose
sur l'oreille droite
quand je devais sur l'oreille gauche
d'apple tape savament activé mon
assistant vocal siri 6-2 sur ios google
assistance si vous êtes sur android et
lorsque sa fille pendant trois secondes
ça va activer la réduction de bruit
active
je trouve que l'idée d'abord miss et
c'est petit pavé tactile c'est bien
c'est intuitif et ça prend très vite et
ça pour moi c'est un assassin points
positifs moins de regret j'aurais aimé
qu'on est une petite application pour
venir régler du moins les quoi liseur on
est un petit peu améliorée tout ça parce
que je trouve que comme ça flatte brut
dans ce que vous les mettez dans vos
oreilles que vous écoutez de la musique
je vous le dis une fois de plus la
qualité est pas génial non et j'espère
que j'y arrive à travailler dessus va
nous faire une petite tape avec des
équaliseur voire pourquoi pas dans
l'application xiaomi hommes semblent pas
être en tout cas les dans le bon sens
autre point positif donc on a une bonne
tenue dans les oreilles alors moi je
vais pas m'amuser pour courir avec un
pour moi si vous allez courir avec vous
allez perdre l'autonomie
et pas mal mais n'est pas folle vous
avez 10 heures d'autonomie
on a mieux sur d'autres produits est ce
que c'est le fait d'avoir la réduction
bruit actif qui va venir un petit peu je
dirais diminué l'autonomie de ces petits
appareils s'est complètement possible à
savoir qu'il se connecte avec du
bluetooth 4 points 2 alors je sais enfin
fait pas trop de cadeaux à ces mini
trous wireless air phone je pense que
c'est une première bonne copie c'est une
bonne idée
je pense que shiomi a besoin d'aller
chercher plus sa personnalité dans ces
produits là à avoir un produit qui lui
correspond un produit qui reflète plus
sa personnalité ou l'idée en tout cas de
la boîte c'est à dire proposer les
meilleures technologies aux tarifs les
plus abordables pour moi là dessus on a
effectivement un tarif très abordable à
79,99 mais pour moi on n'a pas les
meilleures technologies
si chez home is n'est pas ben on va
aller par exemple changer le design
qu'ils aillent au moins se dire on va
améliorer la qualité audio
on va proposer de la haute résolution on
va aller beaucoup plus loin sa part est
vraiment intéressant pour nous un petit
peu titillé les autres voilà un peu pour
ces différents points de regrets alors
je sais je me trouve un petit peu dur
mais moi quand je m'écoute assumer c'est
vraiment ce que ce que je ressens shiomi
j'adore ce que vous faites vous faites
des téléphones qui sont très bien
démontré été très bien des produits
l'écosystème très bien être plein de
produits
moi j'adore votre routine est j'adore
énormément de produits chez vous mais je
pense que ce produit là il va falloir
leur travail et flore l'améliorer il
sort tout va falloir lui donner une
meilleure envergure au niveau audio et
surtout essayer de vous réinventer pour
que quand on voit ça on ne pense pas à
ça parce que ça pour moi c'est
problématique
vous avez votre propre identité vous
avez vos fans il ya des gens qui vous
elle qui vous aime parce que vous êtes
ce que vous êtes alors sain pour moi
voilà c'est pas tout réussir non plus
sur ce je vous embrasse
bisous à demain ciao